putin is assassinating people that don't  agree with them a russian oligarch  allegedly shot his pregnant wife and  daughter before taking his own life in  their multi-million dollar apartment in  moscow the very next day another russian  oligarch did the exact same thing to his  wife and daughter in spain before taking  his own life suspiciously there were no  fingerprints on the weapons no blood  stains on his body and his son strongly  denies that his dad did this both men  were worth more than 400 million dollars  each and both men were at the top of  russia's energy and banking sectors so  why did they die subscribe for part 2 to  find out